[Music]
whoa what kind of airship is that i've
never seen anything like it
baby clade what is the president doing
in our front yard
our entire world is in grave danger i
want you to come with me on an
expedition
i'm not my father
he was the explorer
i know you were just a kid when he went
missing
but now
you're all we got
mr clayton i'm a huge fan thank you of
your dad do you think you could forge
his autograph what
where in the world are we
[Music]
you think you brought the dog sorry
[Music]
we are clearly in uncharted territory
[Music]
hello you probably don't understand a
word i'm saying of course i understand
you huh
dad dad grandpa i'm a grandpa
what is this place the cliffs are alive
and the waters dissolve the flesh off
your bones everything down here is
trying to get a look
[Music]
do you mind if i call you splat you just
kind of give me splat
vibes i guess i deserve that
grandpa's awesome he is not awesome you
gave me a machete for my birthday
classic jaeger claimed i was two
i'm loving this family reunion but come
on we got a world to say
[Music]
we need you to figure this out otherwise
we're doomed we are doomed wait
seriously
no i'm just messing with you
didn't see that coming
[Music]
you